lors de sa première télé en france
qu'est stinat cordula avait des cheveux
longs je suis prêt vrai ou faux alors
que si la faute à des chevaux depuis les
années 90 mais oui nous jugeons que
bouna au milieu de mon cas pour tout
début de ma carrière de mannequin j'ai
coupé le chemin exactement à ta première
télé en france puis la fac en 2004 c'est
dans l'émission nouveau look pour une
nouvelle vie
[Musique]
jérémy je vais vous expliquer je vais
être un peu un metteur en scène des voix
d'apparence donc on va et je vais vous
expliquer comment utiliser vos vêtements
et comment mettre tout ça en valeur elle
est belle mais bel et bien c'est en 2004
à 14 ans